[Music]
hi i'm christopher hine today we're
going to talk about moro tedori
moro tedor is an interesting technique
because i think for most aikido schools
they feel like moro tedor is really core
super core to aikido however if you look
in the old budo rinshi book moro tedori
doesn't exist so which means morote dori
was not a part of the original
aikido-ish or ikibuto syllabus depending
on how you want to delineate aikido and
where it comes from so it is moro the
door is a more modern invention so we're
gonna look at some ideas from rotadori
i'm gonna kind of go through all the
hidoki for them and then we'll talk
about how that those hidoki will
naturally set up the techniques that
become the techniques of morocco i'm
going to call josh out here we're going
to go to work josh
all right so let's talk about marotte
marotte dory i don't i don't know a
really good lineage i don't i don't know
exactly how it appeared but i do know
that it wasn't in the earliest work of
yoshiba and it does appear later and it
becomes a
very prominent technique
and why is is you know a little beyond
this video but we're going to talk about
some of the techniques uh and how they
come in so a moroccan very classically
shown and this is mostly from the obama
system which really loves morocco dory
is the elbow you want the elbow in an up
position you want to have you want to
hold his arms like a sword position so
whatever legs forward that's going to be
the forward arm and i want to have
myself going towards the rear of him
right so meaning if i take my hands off
you can see i'm kind of towards the rear
if i go this way i'm kind of towards the
front so i want to get myself going
towards the rear here i want to grab
this arm give it a little twist and then
i want to drive into that elbow to drive
him down and this is a technique in and
of itself meaning i could take someone
down with this technique right so it's
possible to take someone down with this
okay so that's the basic idea now that
being said in my school the way i train
it is
the door is anytime there's two hands on
one hand right so that's morote dorian
all that's legitimate moro theodori that
being said this is going to be the
strongest version like this version is
super strong you can do more with it it
gives you more control okay what's nice
about this if we look at a weapon and
understand
this is probably always going to be done
as a weapon technique probably if you're
unarmed someone's not going to worry
about the dory because a body hold would
be better but if i went to a body hole
and he had a weapon he's going to load
me up so that's why i would have two
hands on his one hand to hold him so
this is probably always going to include
a weapon of some sort so when i have
that what's really great about this is
if i'm controlling him with morote if he
reaches to switch weapon hands you see
it's super hard for him if he comes up
to get me super super difficult for him
right so i have this position if he
pushes his elbow up then i get ikkyo
right so see i just turned into ikkyo if
he pushes down elbow down we have some
other techniques but that is actually
the best strategy for him is to work his
elbow down so let's go ahead and talk
about that and talk about this without a
knife first and then we'll go into some
more weapon stuff just because it's
easier to show without having to worry
about hitting myself or hitting josh
with the knife for a second okay so he
has my my hand like this right okay what
i want to do the core idea i want to do
is i want to get my elbow down
okay now just by getting my elbow down
if i could manage to do it in a violent
way i might be able to clear my hand
just like that because what this
basically does is it starts tearing my
hand out of his in this way in this way
right so so as i'm going through i'm
popping out like this so that in and of
itself just pushing my elbow down
expressing coq10 through my hand here
and moving into him with my elbow that
might clear so that could be a hadokey
in and of itself if that doesn't work
then i now have my arm under my control
so my body's controlling my arm now as
opposed to him using my arm to control
me this also facilitates switches right
so when we're looking at a knife
situation here if he's trying to control
that knife if i can drop my elbow i
immediately can switch and now he's in a
really bad way he's going to have to
track the knife over here so that
enables switches right off the bat now
there is all kinds of situations where
maybe he's got some kind of grip with
the morote that i can't switch right i
can't open my hand i can't get the knife
out so he's holding it in a way that
won't enable me to do that so i do need
to have other things other than just the
switch in mind so when i get to this
position uh
let's talk about that in one second i'll
talk about the techniques to start to
come off this but let's talk about how
he might give me trouble with this
position okay so i'll stick the knife
away again so we don't have to worry
about it for a second all right so now
one thing he might do is start twisting
my arm like this okay and he can twist
it all the way into a hammer lock right
so he can twist all the way up into this
position that's bad for me all right now
if he's stronger than me and he's
pushing my elbow that way and i'm trying
to push my elbow that way because he's
stronger than me of course he's going to
win and he has a major advantage here
because he's got two hands and i've only
got one so meaning i've got half the
strength even if we were equally
strength i got half the strength as him
if he's stronger than me it's really
really bad so what i'm going to use is a
distraction technique here so instead of
trying to push my elbow straight back
i'm going to push my elbow at an angle
to where he's pushing and it's going to
be really hard to see this maybe i'll
put some arrows on this in editing later
but he's pushing my arm this way so what
i want to do is go at an angle that
doesn't oppose the angle he is so i'm
driving it here and then when i drive it
to the new position that's when i want
to try to start to work it down right so
instead of right here he pushes it over
and me resist him directly i drive it up
to a distraction point which will pull
him a little bit out of his power zone
and i can switch it over so if you see
what happens there when he goes this way
if i pull it like this you see he starts
to kind of get a little discombobulated
so he's not in a strong position as he
was before and then i might have the
ability to drive my elbow down so when
he's twisting my arm i don't want to
fight directly against it i want to pull
it at a different angle and then from
that different angle i start working and
it's not going to be one two like that
right so you're not going to go step one
new angle step two do this because by
the time you get step two he's gonna
readjust and he's to be strong again and
you're not going to get it so it's all
one action where he's pushing my elbow
this way and i pull it and i turn it
down the other the other way and this of
course gives me ecos and eating my nages
and all kinds of stuff can come off of
this but this is just a tactic when i'm
trying to push my elbow down and he's
resisting me to stop that from happening
okay now let's say we get here
to our elbow down position what is it
we're going to do from our elbow down
position well if i could switch i'd
switch if i couldn't switch so he had me
in some way and i'm not even going to
make josh worry about it right now so he
could do a ton of things right to keep
me from switching um but what i'm going
to worry about that right now i'm just
going to i can't switch for whatever
reason right so what can i do well i can
try to slide in here beside him like
this okay and let's move this way just a
pinch so i move slight side in side by
side with him here and this starts to
give me the ability to cook naga him now
when you think kokinagi maybe you think
some big throw that's going to end the
fight all the kokinagi is doing here is
nudging him away so i can start to get
advantages right so could just be that i
start to throw him and he doesn't like
it so he hops off of me but understand
that hopping off of me i got free which
is what i want right so all i'm trying
to do is give him a really hard time and
so that's what this kooky nugget will
allow me to do i start popping his
elbows a little or popping his hips a
little popping his hips a little bit and
i can start to move him around right so
what i don't want is him to stagnate
down and lock down on me in a way that i
can't do anything about it because he's
stronger than me right so i've got to be
nudging him and popping him and moving
him so that way i have i have
opportunities in those movements that
happen okay now let's say this side
isn't working out for me for whatever
reason i can always work this side and
on this side i'm going to probably
primarily work my ikyo here and i'm
going to work my nikyo here if the
elbow's up i'm going to be working my
echo if the elbow's going down i'm going
to be working my kneecap so that's going
to be my main escape ideas going to that
side okay now if i can't get my elbow
down what am i going to do i want to run
around to the front and i'm going to try
to get a myotosh so i'm going to try and
shoot around this side and hit the arms
here to get myotosh in that now when i'm
doing that understand that it's not
going to be easy because i can't when
i'm practicing the technique i can't
allow my elbow to drop because if i
could drop this would be a better
situation i'm trying to train a
technique where my elbow can't drop so
what you're going to do is shoot your
hands straight through as much as you
can this is kind of like the same
distraction technique we talked about
before i'm going to shoot my elbow
through a little bit and then as i do
that i'm going to use that to turn right
here and that's going to put me in
position to pop these elbows as hard as
i can and try and get free there now of
course if i couldn't pop those elbows
free then i'm going to try to work
underneath it we get juji for that we
get a whole series of techniques for
that but that's the idea right so i
can't drop my elbow so i go to the other
side i try my myotosh i can't get my
myotosh i try to slide underneath and i
get juji and a whole bunch of stuff will
come come into that series
okay so now let's say i get in side by
side but every time i try to pop his
hips he he's dancing around in a
controlled way so i mean he's really
pretty controlled and actually let me
take you kimmy for josh for this i'll
show you let's go to this side okay so
as he drops that elbow i'm super
flexible so see i still have full grip
on this guy so just like this my grip
hasn't broken at all and every time he
tries to get close to my hips i kind of
do this number right so let's come over
here a little more so you can see he's
trying to get close to my hips and i'm
not letting him get close to my hips so
i'm staying here and i can't he's got
his elbow down i can't change that he's
too strong for me to change that but i
do have his arm in a second i'm going to
change to a better position so he's got
to work fast but what he's going to do
here is he's going to shoot right
underneath right so he's going to shoot
right here and he gets sankyo and a
whole series of techniques from this
okay so
if you can see this progression you can
understand how the mirote dory is not a
static thing the morote dori is always
moving and evolving and as the person
who's at the disadvantage and that's
where you're practicing aikido from i'm
always at the disadvantaged position my
job is to keep that other guy moving as
much as possible so i can take advantage
of the mistakes that they'll make in the
moving right if i allow them to lock
down on me they're going to hold me and
that's it i'm done for right so i have
to keep things moving so these are the
ways in which i'm going to move go to
this side drop my elbow go to that side
use distraction all these kinds of
things are going to enable me to have a
chance right whereas normally i wouldn't
um
it is already about 100
100 102 in here yeah it's 9 a.m so i
hope it is cooler wherever you are i'm
christopher hyde this is joshua t my
solenoid mcdaniels behind the camera
thanks for watching
[Music]